We've talked about how to create particles and some of the effects achievable.
You can create all sorts of animations with particle systems. Here's an
abstract presentation by AlteredQualia, which includes varying the sizes of
particles over time. Objects can also be formed out of particles. In this demo,
the models are represented by particles instead of wire frame triangles,
allowing interesting transformations to occur. Sets of particles can be used
for all sorts of animations, such as this one with a firework emitting sparks
as it goes. By overlapping particles, you can get fuzzy effects. Of course, you
can always make fireworks themselves. Here's how animators preview some
effects. Particle systems are often set up with guidelines either fixed or with
some randomness. Rules include elements such as when are particles created,
what path it travels and whether it disappears after a certain duration. The
path could be hand-animated or controlled by the laws of physics or even a bit
of both. Another common use is to have large collections of particles simulate
smoke, water or other phenomena. Here, particles are shown with a fountain
effect. The particles don't have to be small, they can be objects in their own
right, such as these dandelion seeds being blown away by the wind. We can also
create particles that are random 3D fragments, which act as if they're
generated from a collision. Even effects such as sparkling logos can be done by
animating particles. Here's the preview followed by the final offline
rendering. Or you can simply use procedural methods to create amazing scenes.
It still astounds me how many particles you can animate and render at once. In
this demo by AlteredQualia, there are 150,000 rotating 3D cubes being thrown at
the screen and I'm getting a frame rate of 28 frames per second. The whole
particle system, evolution itself, creation, movement, and extinction, can now
even be calculated entirely on newer GPUs. This allows more elaborate
animations while also freeing up the CPU for other work.